- Threat of substitutes,
competition from products and services
from outside the industry.
Simply put, the threat
of substitution increases
when customers can find
different ways of doing
what you do for them.
For example, streaming
a movie versus going to
a movie theater.
Another example is
disposable diapers destroying
the cloth diaper industry.
If there are lots of readily
available substitutes,
profits in an industry will tend to fall.
Substitution threats can
take different forms.
Not just lowering the price
firms can charge customers.
Sears for instance, once the
largest retailer in the US,
lost its leadership position.
Sears had entered the
retail industry early
and captured prime
locations on main street
in virtually every city in America.
However, with suburbanization
people stopped
traveling to downtown to go shopping.
They preferred to shop at newly developed
suburban malls.
Sears was now located in the wrong place.
Sears was slow to move
into suburban malls.
This more than anything led to its demise.
Another good example
is the camera industry.
The camera industry has
largely been supplanted
by smart phones.